how do I motivate myself in the mornings  to work out I absolutely never rely on  motivation  ever because I am motivated to sleep in  and stay in my warm bed and I'm  motivated to eat donuts and gummy candy  for breakfast I don't wait for  motivation otherwise I'd be a disaster  so I come up with here's who I'm gonna  be and I reverse engineer a whole series  of behaviors that are going to back up  that identity and I'm a guy who takes  care of his body and that means I'm  going to get rest that means I'm not I'm  going to sleep means I gotta turn my  phone off in the evening things like  that and that means I'm going to  exercise almost every single day